a escasos metros del puerto de Barcelona
buceadores voluntarios y científicos se
dan cita cada mes para explorar el fondo
Marino vale chicos Pues nos preparamos y
vamos al agua es bióloga ya ha venido a
tomar algunos esquejes de las corrgonias
al igual que los corales duros que están
en peligro de extinción estos fueron
descubiertos accidentalmente hace tres
años en las aguas de la capital catalana
un misterio de la naturaleza y una
fuente de Esperanza para los ecologistas
Mira chicos la física del día
forman verdaderos bosques marinos son
como los bosques de tierra pero están
formados por animales muchas especies
ponen sus huevos o se refugian entre
esas ramificaciones vale como aquí en
Barcelona tenemos caballitos de mar o
muchas especies de peces es sorprendente
que estas gorgonias no en un área tan
impactada
para llegar al fondo del Enigma Joseph
María y otros biólogos marinos iniciaron
un proyecto de investigación
el hecho de que proliferen en Barcelona
han adquirido una capacidad adaptativa
importante al cambio climático con lo
cual es un ejemplo desde el punto de
vista biológico ecológico extremadamente
interesante y importante no por las
próximas tres a cinco semanas yo separía
y su equipo van a cultivar gorgonias
para estudiar su resistencia ambientes
contaminados
en los fondos de Barcelona tengamos un
auténtico bosque de gorgonias esto es
realmente único en el Mediterráneo y
espero con el futuro otras ciudades lo
puedan estos científicos dicen que es
vital conservar y regenerar los fondos
marinos de Europa los mares y océanos
del mundo producen al menos el 50% del
oxígeno disponible en la tierra